hello my talk today is called the future
is now and I'm gonna start it off with a
quote linguistically and materially a
hybrid of cybernetic device and organism
a cyborg is a science fiction chimera
from the 1950s and after but a cyborg is
also a powerful social and scientific
reality in the same historical period
like any important technology a cyborg
is simultaneously a myth and a tool a
representation and an instrument a
frozen movement and a motor of social
and imaginative reality a cyborg exists
when two kinds of boundaries are
simultaneously problematic one that the
the that between animals or other
organisms and humans and two that
between self controlled self-governing
machines automate Ahn's and organisms
especially humans which are models of
autonomy the cyborg is the figure born
of the interface of automate automate on
and autonomy this is a quote from Donna
Haraway that introduces the first
chapter to the cyborg handbook which is
a work that is a collection of studies
essays and fiction on the societal and
political circumstances around cyborgs
the fundamental description I think
helps us shape how we view the concept
of ways that technology utilizes not
just the machine
the machine human hybrid and it's not
just limited to the actual pure
visualization of what we think of when
we hear cyborg but it also extends to
the relationship we have with artificial
intelligence becoming increasingly
involved in our everyday lives so today
we'll be discussing things of a
cyberpunk nature from subverting AI
biohacking and finally an art series
that I'm working on that visualizes
modern cybernetic augmentation so hi my
name is Rachel white and I'm a
technologist artist and Technical
Evangelist at Microsoft
I'm Ojo on Twitter I already said that
I'm also the artist in residence or it
was over the summer at a space in
Brooklyn called pioneer Works which is a
space that allows artists to have
residency's to focus on their specific
areas of art and technology that they
work on and I was the technology and
residents which means art and technology
so I built these things which you should
ignore until later which I know is gonna
be difficult so I'm not interested in
machine learning and artificial
intelligence necessarily for commercial
applications do not tell Microsoft that
I'm more interested in the ways that we
interact with technology and the
emotional connection that we can make
with it I think that the most important
way that we can further these fields is
to make people unafraid of them by means
of Education unfortunately the majority
of commercial aspects are used to help
further the police state and the Nabal
discrimination of those most
marginalized therefore when I work on
these projects I try and make it as
non-threatening as possible and I try
and make it a delightful experience for
users feel okay with the interaction I
open-source as much as I can that way
not only can people take away a good
interaction but they can also learn from
it and interact with the code themselves
because I feel that if we know the way
that a lot of these emerging
technologies work behind the scenes
it'll not only be easier to subvert it
when it's being used for dangerous
applications but we'll be able to
recognize what it's being used that way
as well so to start we've got to talk
about the major theme of this talk and
that's cyberpunk so what exactly is
cyberpunk it's more than just a hashtag
aesthetic although I've really enjoyed
this aesthetic it's a good book it's
extremely popular right now as an
aesthetic and film and popular media and
all different kinds of art so what's
actually cyberpunk cyberpunk is a
sub-genre of science fiction in a future
setting that tends to focus on society
as high tech low life me IRL featuring
featuring advanced technological and
scientific achievements such as
information technology and cybernetics
juxtaposed with a degree of breakdown or
radical change in the social order I
think this is super topical today
a lot of the issues that we've been
facing the need for protecting privacy
is more important than ever
not just securing personal data but
securing personal identities as well a
lot of the work that we'll be talking
about today and a lot of the work that's
done at the intersection of art and tech
in terms of privacy and the kind of
cyberpunk thing deals with protecting
yourself from data collection from
corporations in the government so this
talk is called the future is now because
so much so many of the cyberpunk dreams
of the future that's iterated over in
the science fiction literature of the
past 50 years or at our fingertips today
although the science fiction of the 80s
is what really shaped our views of what
cyberpunk is now I wanted to read this
excerpt from the preface of the
cyberpunk anthology called mirror shades
because they think it's extremely
relevant to all of the work that we're
gonna discuss today for the cyberpunks
by stark contrast technology is visceral
it is not the bottle genie of remote big
science boffins it is pervasive utterly
intimate not outside us but next to us
under our skin often inside our minds
technology itself has changed
not for us the Giants team snorting
wonders of the past the Hoover Dam the
Empire State Building the nuclear power
plant 80's text sticks to the skin
responds to the touch the personal
computer the Sony Walkman the portable
telephone the soft contact lens CERN
central themes spring up repeatedly in
cyberpunk the theme of body invasion
prosthetic limbs implanted circuitry
cosmetic surgery genetic alteration even
more powerful theme of mind invasion
brain computer interfaces artificial
intelligence neural chemistry techniques
radically redefining the nature of
humanity the nature of the self and so
that being said let's just jump right
into it so the first piece of work that
I want to talk about is CV dazzle Adam
Harvey is an artist and designer if we
came up with CV dazzle while at NYU's
interactive telecommunications program
ITP
and the purpose is to explore how
fashion can
Verte facial recognition software which
uses precise data to determine whether
or not a face is present if one obscures
part of the face that they know is being
used in these type of algorithms it
becomes possible to trick the machine so
altering facial symmetry gradations and
shift in skin tone as well as obscuring
the bridge of the nose which makes the
machine and capable of determining
features so the project utilizes these
kind of hair extensions and makeup
because the facial recognition
algorithms really do look for symmetry
even if you have like 90s emo bangs at
over one eye it won't really know
there's a face sometimes so the whole
project is dealing with makeup and hair
and just playing with like what is the
expectation of a machine well a human
design algorithm that a machine is
running to pick faces and I think that
this is super cool the next thing that I
wanted to talk about is identity kit
identity kit is an INT anti-surveillance
piece and they're they're pieces that
are reoccur a lot at the intersection of
tech and science or tech and art the
identity kit project is from a student
at the Rhode Island School of Design and
it also tackles the issue of biometric
authentication using identity kit anyone
can cover their real fingerprint with a
fake one that is fully functional
replaceable and practically impossible
to copy it's a sticky black prosthetic
made from a mixture of conductive
silicone and a random mess of carbon
fibers so it emulates the ridges on your
fingertip like when you're unlocking
your phones once you wrap it around your
finger you're then able to unlock any
kind of device that requires
fingerprint authentication and if you
feel that it's been compromised it's
just as easy to swap it out for a
different one I think that this piece is
really important because biometric
authentication and surveillance is
pretty terrifying considering 5.6
million government employees and
contractors had their fingerprints
stolen in a data breach a few years ago
it makes sense to take into
consideration other ways to get around
biometric authentication so one thing
that I hear a lot when people are
talking about facial recognition for
unlocking devices and finger
some stuff is like it's time to your
body it's the most secure type of
authentication you could possibly have
but if you're in handcuffs and a cop has
your phone and he's holding it up to
your your new shiny iPhone to your face
like they can get access to your data
and it's not actually you can't give
them your password but they can totally
you know brute force your face that's on
ya I'm gonna stick with that so the next
thing that I'm going to talk about is
transhumanism and what is transhumanism
transhumanism is an emergent
philosophical movement which says that
humans can and should become more more
than human through technological
enhancements contemporary transhumanism
has grown out of white male affluent
Americans internet culture and it's
political perspective has generally been
a militant version of the libertarianism
typical of that culture sounds sounds
great a lot of the early pioneers of
transhumanism as a concept we're
libertarians they were really only
invested in their own self-interest by
means of life extension and not
transhumanism for all as a greater good
this is an important back history on the
movement as the next thing that we're
going to talk about is biohacking
so what is bio hacking bio hacking is
physical modifications to your body
people that do those kinds of bio
hacking are called grinders and grinders
are people who apply of a hacker ethic
to improve their own bodies with
do-it-yourself cybernetic devices so the
bio hackers that are doing this are the
ones that are trying the modifications
before it's legal so even if you go to
like a piercing shop and get a piercing
or go to a tattoo shop and get a tattoo
those are like I don't know some kind of
government controlled process where
they're like this person's certified to
do that these people don't really follow
those guidelines you'll see
don't worry there's content warnings for
Gore grinders are passionate individuals
who believe the tools and knowledge of
science belong to everyone
grinders practice functional extreme
body modification in an effort to
improve the human condition
grinders hacked themselves with
electronic hardware to extend and
improve human capacities grinders
believe in action their bodies are the
experiment so this is the kind of
biohacking that I'm most interested in
this is an implant called the North Star
by a grinder group based in Pittsburgh
called grind house wetware when you
visit their site the splash page says
who would you like to be today and I was
like that's nice so the North Star v1
implant is just for aesthetic purposes
you place a magnet near the device in
the lights brighten which means that
they're probably using a Hall sensor
which uses magnets to complete the
circuit but it also means that there's a
battery in them which I'm glad that
they're trying this stuff out because I
I personally wouldn't put a battery in
me so there is another kind of bio
hacking that I briefly wanted to touch
on because I hate it and it also calls
back to the transhumanism explanation of
it being like white male off fluid stuff
so there's a recent trend in
performance-enhancing snake oil being
shelled by ironically those that believe
in red pilling is an actual thing so I
mean there's also like noah tropic kind
of biohacking
with people micro dosing LSD and that's
totally different this is just crap
these kind of noah tropics I'm talking
about our smart drugs or cognitive
enhancers they're drugs
supplements or other substances that
improve cognitive function particularly
executive functions memory creativity or
motivation and healthy individuals which
is really interesting because the two
examples I'm about to give you I would
not call creative motivated or healthy
so Mike Stern of it has a great Noah
tropic
gorilla mine has Noah tropic stack is
free growing neurons in my mind I can
feel them growing as I drift up to sleep
amazing so yeah he sells those and then
of course Alex Jones this the most
mentally stable man alive cells one
called brain force 25% off which is
ironically probably also his mental
capacity optimize your health and help
support the infowar these are really
popular I feel like anybody that would
spend the money deserves it I don't oh
so who is biohacking
and what are they getting magnetic
implants are really popular nowadays
what they what they do is they make a
small incision at the fingertip and then
put in a flat disk magnet and then sew
it up and then you can feel electrical
current I do not have one because I
remember when I had a cathode ray
television and it would be on in a room
you know the screen wasn't on and you
know when you walk in there and you know
the TV's on even though it's not you can
like somehow feel it being able to feel
that all the time would be kind of
terrible if you have one and that's not
what it's like please tell me but that's
my impression of being able to feel
electrical waves all the time the next
type is an NFC tag this is the
non-invasive kind so this tag you can
actually buy from Adafruit there's been
a lot of people that have done a lot of
work with acrylic and gel nail art where
they put the NFC tag in there there's
actually a woman in London who soaked
her oyster transit card in acetone to
get the NFC tag out of it that had all
of her subway like stuff on it put it on
her nails so she could just be like when
you get in which is really cool so so
basically with this NFC tag you get
close to the RFID reader and it gets
powered by the reader causing the light
to brighten NFC chips evolved from our
RFID which is radio frequency
identification and it operates as one
part of a wireless link
so you're just completing a circuit with
the NFC tag being a part of it
they carry small amounts of data between
the two and advice to devices and they
are usually readable and writeable it's
also fast and easy unless it's in your
body which um that's the next time we're
gonna talk about these are invasive NFC
tags this is a tag that you can purchase
from a site called dangerous things they
also have a map of body modification
artists who do the implants for you I
have one so if you live in Brooklyn and
need a suggestion I can let you know if
you want to know what it says you have
to find me later and have an Android
phone and scan it because I'm not no
spoilers
so people have typically used these to
open their car doors House doors Zoe
Quinn put a download for Deus Ex on
theirs yeah it's it's it's one of the
most common I would say common popular
body modifications for biohacking
this is what it looks like it's about
the size of a long grain of rice and
it's readable and writeable they put it
right here
I'm you're probably not close enough to
see this but I'll show you later and it
doesn't hurt um I mean I'm a programmer
so I was back to work the same day it's
no problem
but like what else is biohacking people
who are getting cosmetic surgery or
people who are taking care of their
fertility through birth control devices
or biohacking there's kind of an
ignorance towards these kind of body
modifications is being seen as cyborg ii
and i really wonder why um it's almost
like how Soylent is a revolutionary
concept of meal replacement when all
they did was take a concept that people
had already been utilizing and decided
to market it to nerds
we're all nerds it's fine Soylent bad
anyway I can't have a cyberpunk in
biohacking talk without mentioning
Neuromancer so if you're not familiar
with Neuromancer it's a 1984 novel by
William Gibson it's a seminal work in
the cyberpunk genre and the first winner
of the science fiction triple crown
which is the Nebula Award the philip k
dick award and the Hugo Award
it was Gibson's debut novel and the
beginning of the sprawl trilogy the
novel tells the story of a washed-up
computer hacker hired by a mysterious
employer to pull off the ultimate hack
the hacker whose name is case Jackson to
cyberspace by slotting a tiny Microsoft
no relation chip into the space behind
his ear
but the case isn't the only really
awesome bio hacker in the book my
personal favorite Mali Millions Molly's
metabolism sensory input and reflexes
are artificially heightened by means of
electronic implants and other advanced
medical procedures
she has razor sharp retractable blades
under her fingernails which is
personally a life goal each double edged
and therefore centimeters in length and
appearing at first glance to be wearing
mirrored sunglasses
she actually has her eye socket sealed
with vision enhancing mirrored lenses
and to accommodate the inset lenses this
is really badass her tear ducts have
been rerouted to her mouth and on the
very rare occasion that she cries she
spits it out or swallows her tears
and then of course there's the game Deus
Ex this series set during the 21st
century focus on the conflict between
secretive factions who wish to control
the world by proxy and the effects of
trans humanistic attitudes and
technologies in a dystopian future
setting you're able to swap out and
upgrade your body parts for better
mechanical parts and a lot of people who
are interested in bio hacking today
we're extremely inspired by their
experiences placing or playing this game
so hold on a second all of these are
important because I'm mostly here to
talk to you today about my projects new
romance looks familiar right
it's basically an ongoing art project
where I was inspired by a lot of you for
mentioned things so new romance is the
name of a series of pieces that I
started working on while beginning my
residency at Pioneer works the first two
pieces which are here today that I'm
gonna show you they utilize motion
pictures special effects techniques
combined with hardware to visualize what
modern cybernetic augmentation could
look like based off of our societal of
political wants and needs so I do have a
Content warning for gore its simulated
gore if there's anybody that doesn't
want to see it you can I don't know
raise your hand and close your eyes and
I'll give you a warning or I'll let you
know when it's done
it's all fake blood but I have some
friends that can't like that aren't here
thank God that can't handle it so
alright so I've always been inspired and
interested in practical effects used in
film and I admired mired artists like
Tom Savini who worked with George Romero
and the Living Dead films Rob Bottin who
worked with John Carpenter on the thing
the FX used in David Cronenberg's videos
room and of course everything that Rick
Baker has ever touched the combination
of sculpture puppetry realistic painting
and often the DIY ethic of having to
figure out how to rig up the props when
it was something that no one had done
before is what impressed me and really
me to learn how to do it luckily the the
art school that I went to had a special
effects program so I just bothered them
all the time to teach me everything that
they possibly could and this was oh
three two oh six so I've had a lot of
time to practice and they did teach me
and I got kind of good at it so after
years of going really overboard during
Halloween I started getting pretty
decent um it was like countless hours of
watching YouTube videos on how to do
prosthetics and how to paint stuff
accurately devouring every single season
of face off and even getting asked to
try out myself I haven't it's too much
time I really threw myself into the
hobby if I had never gone to college or
wasn't involved in tech I couldn't
definitely see this being something that
I could do luckily I can cover myself in
fake blood at my spare time so aside
from my interest in horror and gory
things in general I'm also a huge
science-fiction fan I have the worst
tattoo of data from Star Trek that
you've ever seen in your life
it looks like Steven Seagal or Frank or
Frankenstein I actually got it in st.
Louis I just remembered that
not telling me where I love diving into
dystopian fiction although I never
really knew why I never really read any
actual Studies on the genre so once I
started doing more research into why it
always piqued my interest I found a
common theme throughout the same kind of
politics that I tend to follow and that
was rooted in the inherent evil of class
struggle and people rising up to fight
those oppressing them so like I'm not
saying that like that's really cool
dystopian futures are rad
I was just like yeah they should like
kick their asses so that typically fits
the kind of high tech / low life themes
that a lot of cyberpunk
stuff throughout film literature and
games has the lower class is modifying
themselves in order to fight back any
way that they can to get an upper hand
so that like also follows through with
the grinder athos of DIY body hacking so
though a small amount of the grinders
are experimenting with augmentation are
actually doing helpful modifications I
was interested in that people are
experimenting with putting these things
into their bodies just because they
could and I really do believe that it's
a first step towards more useful
applications so knowing all of these
things about myself and my interest I
really wanted to read other perspectives
so I really really dope into the
research I should have went to papers we
love because I've read so many in the
past few months when I thought about the
things that like drew me to cyberpunk I
never thought about the implications of
how centered it was on the white male
experience since we're so conditioned to
not really noticing those kinds of
things until somebody's like makes you
realize it and then you start noticing
it everywhere so when I started reading
a lot of critical theory about cyborgs
and cybernetics my mind was blown by how
much I was overlooking and the work that
people already done and so much of it
that I agreed with so the first thing
that I read was the Xena feminism
manifesto which the organizers of it say
describe it as a techno materialist anti
naturalist and gender abolitionist form
of feminism
xeno feminists want to see roles
reversed and Technology democratized
that it can be accessible to everyone
which obviously that sounds fantastic
the next thing that I read is the cyborg
manifesto
it's a 1984 essay written by Donna
Haraway which deals with the socialist
feminism perspective it discusses a
masculine bias in scientific culture and
she says cyborg politics have been
linked to oppressive mythologies and
scientific progress racism
male-dominated capitalism and the
exploitation of nature to serve the
needs of culture and so I started diving
deeper of these and I just deeper into
these things and I just found myself
wanting to read more and more on the
subject and then someone suggested to me
the cyborg handbook and like a handbook
sounds great so I I bought it it's not a
handbook it's a textbook it's a textbook
that's literally this thick and it's
categorized as cultural studies science
and science fiction and it has a huge
variation on cyborg proliferation from
just theory to medical application
militarization fictional pieces women is
the first cyborg is a more social and
political theory so if you're interested
in that absolutely buy it it's amazing I
was so overwhelmed so this is my journey
into learning about how I fit with
cyberpunk you know I saw Blade Runner I
read some philip k dick then I got an
RFID implant myself then I read Donna
Haraway
and then I was like sure I'll make a
cyborg I hope I'm using that meme right
so I decided this was the best way to
describe my journey so I wanted to read
this quote from the cyborg manifesto
before I show you these things the main
trouble with cyborgs of course is that
they are the illegitimate offspring of
militarism and patriarchal capitalism
not to mention state socialism but
illegitimate offspring are often
exceedingly unfaithful to their origins
their fathers after all are in essential
and I was like damn Donna
so I was taking this as the cue for a
huge motivation for my project ignoring
the in essential factors that came
before us how can we shape our own
vision of what it means to be a cyborg
for those who haven't had their own
ideals centered in the cyberpunk or
science-fiction realm for the last who
knows how many years so what would
people get if they could modify
themselves what are they getting and
what would they get if the societal and
political circumstance made it possible
so let's let's look at them okay so the
hands is the first piece that I did this
this little one when I started thinking
about what kinds of things people would
want Eggman de jour what kind of
modifications people would want my first
thought was vanity and so the age of
social media is obsessed with
notifications and followers and being
incredibly outlined at all times so sure
there's push notifications and jewelry
and stuff but I was like if someone
could get an LED in their hand that told
them when someone was mentioning them in
social media they totally would so I
decided to make it I mean I would let's
be honest so I decided to make a hand
that has a LED ring embedded in the back
of it and with the help of some of my
friends I cast my hand in silicone we
used some plaster bandages to brace it
and then so since I was casting silicone
into silicone the only thing that sticks
to silicone is silicone which was a
problem so I had to release the mold
really well it was my first time casting
or molding or working with this kind of
silicone before so I was a little bit
worried so I threw all this glitter at
the end of it so that people wouldn't be
afraid of it but the problem was I did a
really good job so nobody wanted to like
touch it but they did in the nails broke
off and stuff but yeah so I painted it I
tinted it and then I embedded the
hardware in it and so people were still
super creeped out so this is what it
looks like and now I'm going to show you
what it does
all right so this is the hand it's my
hand it's this one it looks really good
so this hand actually monitors social
media so if you want to tweet using this
hashtag here's an example because it is
about my ego you can say watching oh-hoh
demo a cybernetic hand it's strange loop
stl hashtag new romance and ideally it
should light up we'll see it'll probably
honestly break though cool somebody's
talking about me oh yay so that's the
hands and the next thing that I decided
to do was a face so I already dealt with
my ego and vanity with social media so
for the second piece I decided to
collaborate with a friend and my friend
Angelina is hopeful cyborg which is you
know suitable for this project and they
wrote something for me that I wanted to
read about their their experience with
transhumanism so Angelina says my
transhumanism has played a pivotal role
in asserting my autonomy in a world that
seeks to assign me baggage and
expectations that I both fail to relate
to and I'm fundamentally uninterested in
transhumanism has played a pivotal role
in giving me the tools to reject this
and to assert my identity and autonomy
the idea that I'm not limited by my
flesh that I may be that I may be more
than my flesh and that my flesh is mine
to do what I wish with is an important
form of liberation from a young age I
knew I wanted to explore this idea fully
beyond tattoos and piercings I already
have several implants that people cannot
see that augment how I experience the
world the decision to visibly alter and
augment my vessel and to perform these
experiments for the world including this
project with Rachel means that I become
a representation of a possibility I am
actively transforming myself to become
who I already am in a way the world can
see and understand I want people to
understand that it is possible for them
to do the same to me what we are doing
in this project isn't science fiction or
fantasy it's a serious prototype for a
future that feels only five minutes away
we started the same processes of the
hand watching a lot of videos for face
lifecasting so that I didn't suffocate
my friend still silicone and after the
silicone had set we put plaster bandages
around their face to create a protective
shell while making sure that they could
still breathe obviously and then after
that was done I had a silicone negative
I cast some hydrocal plaster into that
silicone negatives that I'd have a more
permanent positive to be able to create
things on top of it in the future and
from the plaster positive I was going to
make a plaster negative which is that I
could then brush silicone into to make
my life easier but I'm inpatient and I
did not wait for the plaster to dry long
enough so I was back in the same spot as
the hand and I had to cast silicone into
silicone which made me really angry so I
took a break from the molding and I
decided to focus back on the electronics
for a little bit I am hot glued all of
the RGB LEDs into the pattern that I
needed them to be in for the application
of the face i soldered them all into
series with a ton of resistors ton of
wires and I connected them to the PWM
Arduino shield that I was using that I
needed in order to drive I think it's 15
or 16 RGB LEDs off of one Arduino Uno
and I found I'm not gonna saw her again
for a really long time so once the
hardware part was mostly done I was
ready to get back to the casting I mixed
up some silicone that I tinted to be
closer to flesh tone and added in red
blue and yellow flocking to simulate
fatty tissue and capillaries and then I
poured it into the extremely extremely
well released silicone negative mold
Evangeline's face waited for the first
layer to set and then once the first
layer was set I packed all the
electronics in hope for the best because
if this didn't come out Angelina was
gonna have to come hang out again and I
was gonna have to put silicone on them
and I didn't want to do that but it came
out perfect the first try next thing I
did was I painted on the face with
silicone pigment because silicone only
sticks to silicone I was really pleased
with how realistic it looked because I
was the first time that I ever used an
airbrush to plus facial recognition
chin ups and thought that it was a real
face so I knew that I did a pretty good
job so after that I built a control
panel for the face that has three
potentiometers with some very nice
machine knobs from Adafruit on top I
used some mirrored acrylic that has the
logo of the project pleaser cut into it
and like I said before the face is
running off of an Arduino Uno with a 16
channel 12 bit PWM servo shield on top
and for this one I wrote actually both
of them are just no js' applications but
they're very simple nodejs applications
if you're actually interested in that
you can ask me later
I show code all the time I wanted to
like take a break this time
so now I'd really love to show you the
face actually it's bright enough it's
bright enough that I don't need to put
my camera on so one second
Oh hold on I got to change my node
version sorry all right
so cool so the way that this works is
there are RGB LEDs embedded right under
the skin and it comes down here to the
control panel that I have and then I'm
able to turn the potentiometers so that
I can have a form of digitalized makeup
under the skin it's really neat and I
was basically interested in doing it
this way because it allows you to alter
your appearance without having to apply
anything superficially to the skin so
this is this is Angelina and they can
have whatever color makeup they want
that's the face for next week cool so
what now so I have these two pieces and
my artist residency is ended so what's
next for one this project isn't over for
me I feel like I've barely scratched the
surface on the commentary and
exploration that I'd really like to
achieve so I want to talk to you I want
to talk to those of you who are
underrepresented and who have any
interest in cyberpunk biohacking and
transhumanism and I want to talk to
those of you who have thought about ways
that you could enhance yourself if it
was technologically feasible I'm
interested in the social issues
political issues and personal issues
that tie you to being interested in this
sort of thing so I'd like to leave you
with this quote which is one that I'm
now thinking of constantly when I'm
working and whether that be professional
or personal work or a blend of the same
technology is not neutral we're inside
of what we make and it's inside of us
we're living in a world of connections
and it matters which ones get made and
on
and that's donna haraway again so thank
you
[Applause]